la presidenta municipal bárbara botello
quiere saber cómo se sienten los
residentes de su municipio acerca del
plan educativo propuesto cuál de los
siguientes métodos de encuesta permitirá
a la presidenta municipal bárbara hacer
una conclusión válida acerca de cómo se
sienten los residentes de su distrito
sobre el plan propuesto
antes que incluso miremos esto tenemos
que darnos cuenta que para que podamos
hacer una conclusión válida de cómo se
sienten los residentes de su distrito
entero sobre el plan propuesto ella
tiene que encontrar una muestra
representativa y no una muestra sesgada
que sólo mostraría algunos puntos de
vista de su distrito
así que miremos sus opciones
debería de solo preguntar a sus vecinos
bueno sus vecinos seguramente vive en
una parte del vecindario que pueden no
beneficiarse normalmente de su plan
educativo o puede dañarse por su plan
educativo por lo que preguntar solo a
sus vecinos no representaría al distrito
completo así que preguntar solo a sus
vecinos probablemente no tenga sentido
preguntar a los residentes de una
comunidad de retiro así que una vez más
la primera queda fuera por la geografía
ella está sobre muestreando a sus
vecinos y no al distrito entero aquí
ella está sobre muestreando a edades
específicas aquí ella está muestreando
residentes de edad mayor que podrían
tener opiniones muy diferentes a
residentes de edad media o más jóvenes
tampoco tiene sentido
preguntar a 200 residentes de su
distrito cuyos nombres se hayan escogido
al azar bueno eso suena razonable no se
ve como existe la posibilidad que de
alguna manera se sobre muestre una
dirección u otra pero es más probable
que de una muestra razonablemente
representativa y ésta es un tamaño de
muestra bastante grande es importante
decir cuál es el proceso al azar de
dónde obtendrá estos nombres pero esto
de hecho parece razonable
preguntar a un grupo de padres en un
parque de juegos local bueno una vez más
esto es como preguntar a sus vecinos y
solo está muestreando a una población
específica esta podría ser el grupo a la
que le importan más las escuelas pero
ella quiere saber cómo se siente el
distrito completo sobre sus planes
escolares
y además esta tendrá lugar en un parque
de juegos local y no en todos los
parques de juegos del distrito así que
tampoco haría esta hagamos una más
miriam quiere hacer una encuesta de sus
300 compañeros de clase para determinar
cuál candidato a la presidencia vino
domínguez o bruno morales está a la
cabeza de las próximas elecciones mire a
preguntara si la elección fuera hoy cuál
candidato tendría tu voto cuáles de los
siguientes métodos para encuestar a sus
compañeros permitirá a miriam hacer
conclusiones válidas de qué candidato va
a la cabeza
veamos preguntar a todos los estudiantes
de la mesa del almuerzo de bruno no eso
se crearía el resultado a favor de bruno
probablemente esa no es una muestra
representativa preguntar a todos los
miembros del equipo de soccer de nino no
pasaría lo mismo votarán a favor de nino
o tal vez no tal vez no les gustan y no
tal vez están en contra de mi no pero de
todas maneras esa parece ser una muestra
sesgada poner el nombre de todos los
estudiantes en un sombrero y tomar 50
nombres preguntar a esos estudiantes
cuyos nombres fueron tomados bueno esta
parece una buena muestra al azar que
puede representar adecuadamente a la
población entera
preguntar a todos los estudiantes cuyos
nombres empiecen con n o b
bueno esta puede parecer como si fuera
al azar pero no está la m es la primera
letra de nino y b es la primera letra de
bruno y podría decir que es justo la
están haciendo para cada una de las
letras pero tal vez hay como 10 personas
cuyo nombre empieza con n y solo dos
personas cuyo nombre empieza con be una
vez más ni siquiera estás obteniendo una
muestra grande y también tal vez hay un
tipo de personas que debido a la primera
letra de su nombre prefieren a uno u
otro candidato por lo que descartaría
está
preguntar a todos los estudiantes de la
clase bueno eso funcionaría ya saben hay
300 compañeros de clase eso podría ser
no tan tardado y podría ser una muy
buena bueno más bien no puedes obtener
una mejor respuesta que preguntar a
todos en la población cuáles de los
siguientes métodos para encuestar a sus
compañeros permitirá a miriam hacer
conclusiones válidas de qué candidato va
a la cabeza bueno esa es una conclusión
bastante buena la gente podría cambiar
de opinión así que no es algo definitivo
pero puedes obtener una mejor respuesta
en la población entera
asignar números a cada estudiante en la
clase y utilizar un programa de
computadora para generar 50 números al
azar entre 1 y 300 preguntar a esos
estudiantes cuyos números sean
seleccionados bueno esta es muy parecida
a la de poner los nombres de los
estudiantes en un sombrero y tomar 50
nombres así que elegiré también esta que
parece también ser razonable